[Music]
all right next question
all right next question let me
choose another one
all right
i grew up in a christian home where
wearing pants as a lady is not allowed
when i was younger i did as i was as i
was told and did not question why we
were not allowed to wear pants
okay but
now i am a teenager and i get asked why
i do not wear pants okay sometimes i
honestly wish i could wear them casually
or casually throughout during the week
but not on sabbath
my question is is it a sin for women to
wear trousers i kept leaning because a
coyote walked past my window and i don't
see them very often so i just i love to
see god's feet just stroll by as though
he lives here anyway that's why i was
looking at him all right
give me the question now it should we
wear pounds
is it yeah is it a sin for women to wear
trousers
i don't see how it is a sin
i just don't see how this is a sin
um
their child's women their trousers for
men
there are some parts of the world where
women wear what looks like trousers
and you go to india or other such
countries they wear a sort of a pants
looking thing there's trousers we may
not call it trousers they may call it
something else is india but i it depends
on
what how it's made for whom it's made
trousers made for women don't look like
trousers made for men now we're talking
about these type type things that look
as if they were painted on by somebody
that's a different story altogether i'm
not talking about that that shows every
curve every line every piece of cell you
like i am not referring to that i'm
referring to something that does not
something loose fitting that that is
modest and to be really normal you know
what modesty is near the guidance of the
spirit of god to understand modesty but
i don't see how someone can say a pants
is a sin
there are some places where men wear
skirts they look like skirts i was
preaching last night for a church in
fiji and the man of the pulpit had
skirts that's the culture that's what
they wear now i call it skirt skirt is
not the word i know that in scotland the
men were killed they look like skirts
but you can't put a kilt on me are you
following me that's not my culture and
so i can't say a pants is a sin i will
say modesty being properly covered
when adam and eve sinned they made
aprons of leaves they were partially
covered when god covered them he made
coats there was total coverage you see
and so that's one of the fundamental
principles but not um
i can't say a pencil is a sin no i can't
say that not at all i don't see where
the bible says or i love why people go
to deuteronomy 22 verse 5. we don't
really want preparedness to put what
pertains to matter what pertains to a
woman
and i'm perfectly fine with that
but a bodice you won't find me wearing a
bodice you can tell that belongs to a
woman it's not a shirt are you following
me about it do people still use the word
bodies
i have no idea what that is to be honest
okay
a bodice is like a shirt for a woman i i
guess i just dated myself uh well you
check the dictionary see what about b or
d i c e you know it's a woman's upper c
upper garment
which uh i guess is equivalent to a
man's shirt it looks it's a feminine
garment you'll never see a man in that
unless well let me know say that you
won't see a man in there and so i cannot
say pants is a sin no i can't say that
at all
not at
all i've seen many pants they shouldn't
wear
i'm seeing i've seen men in pants they
should not wear i'm very serious
and i've seen women in dresses they
should not wear
because modesty was out the window
the thing is the glory of god you see
that principle guides us if you truly
convert it the spirit of god will tell
you things not found in elohim are not
expressively written in the bible the
spirit of god one of his functions is to
say no my daughter no my son this does
not glorify god
i've said it before when you go to the
closet to pick a dress or a suit
is this for the glory of god
and for what i've seen if people would
ask that question they would not wear 90
of the things they wear whether pants or
shirts or whatever they want to wear
them
because they know in their hearts this
is not for god's glory this is for me
i can't call pants to sing
i can call have nudity a sin
i can call it's part of your body
falling out i can call that a sin
you have this expression in this world
we have under boobs and side boobs
that's where people dress
you see and no no no that's just that's
not modest
no no no no
you